Trevor told me that you inspired a song
based off Crocs Yara got me these Crocs
right and she inspired a song have a
song when you have him called my Crocs
in your Crocs and she's solely the so
you had these onset and she and yes she
got me these first season and then I
made as long as I got to play his own
she was like what you hear the song you
have a song fired by yeah tell me what
inspired this gift first of all why is
it a thumb now yeah but one thing I told
him was he can't tell everybody I
inspired but he told me but anyway I
mean the talented musician he also only
wears Crocs okay um it's just like a
funny fact that's what I love about
Trevor is the fact that he is he's like
so smooth and then will you look down
he's in big right anyway the only story
that exists is that I gifted him a pair
of Crocs and have you heard the song I
have did you laugh okay I can't wait to
hear this what is it even about your
good song um I I think it's a little
off-brand for me okay
as Yara Megan is so good and it's so
true okay is it trap is it trap talking
about crotch what is it it's so good you
just have to listen to it you're all
gonna do something we've never done
before yeah this is just the next year
sophomore year you know Zoe and Lucas
still going strong can I help you know
being adorable delighted fight it Aaron
is the RA now of Hawkins trying to use
to push his political agenda while also
loving the single life he was I don't
know if that can be true because we know
there's a little bit of heartbreak and
if we're picking up right after right
after Zoey and Luka got together are we
gonna see you kind of go through the
motions when your heart was broken in
your life have you ever admitted to it I
have maybe the guy no no not until later
okay so we made you see a bit of a salt
you know yeah but you know he's chill
he's not you know he's supporting this
why can't you just admit that guys get
upset over breakups to Zoey it's still
not the same are we gonna have a bitter
Aaron because he's never in group and it
seems like he may deal with a little bit
of heartbreak I don't know I mean I we
do get to see first episode just the
fact that everyone's seen each other
again for the first time so it is funny
to see that kind of transition based on
where we left off last season but
nonetheless he's in the front he's in
the friend group but we know X is always
finding their way back but I don't see
cash being the next that comes back this
season is there any truth to that cash
to Vinci he's not on TV I thought it was
a known fact all right again I'm not
gonna be the weak link so you're not
gonna feel
you
[Music]